- What up internet?
My name is Nancy and
today I'm gonna be walking
around the BuzzFeed office
trying to see if my coworkers
know how to say my last name.
How long have we been friends?
- Almost a year?
- A little over a year.
- For a good half a year.
- Would you say that we're good friends?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, we're good friends, we hang.
- I've been to your house.
- Do you know how to
pronounce my last name?
(record scratch)
- Oh, no no no no no, I can't do it.
- Noy-wen.
- Ehhh...
No.
- I don't want to try 'cause I feel like
I'm gonna mess it up.
- It's Noo-yin?
I had a friend in high
school named Julian Noo-yin.
- It's not.
- Waynge?
- No.
- It's Noo-wen?
- It's still wrong.
- I feel like I just blew your mind.
- I've been saying Noy-wen
since middle school.
- N'wen.
- Alright I'll take that.
- Wen?
Hmmm?
- It's actually Wheng.
- Wang. Wang?
Wheng.
- Oh, I don't want to try again.
- Wheng.
- Wang.
Everybody always says Wang.
It's Wheng.
- What? Can you come
closer and say that again?
- Wheng.
- Wayne?
- You're just saying Wayne now.
- I wanna crawl into
your mouth and figure out
where you're holding the word.
- Wheng.
- Whang?
- That's actually good.
- So the thing about
the Vietnamese language,
is that it's a monosyllabic language,
so every single word is only one syllable.
So Nguyen is one word, so
Noy-wen is not correct.
A lot of the sounds that
goes into my last name,
doesn't really exist in
the English language.
- Nancy told me how to pronounce
her last name last year,
and my dentist has the same last name,
so I was able to call her doctor Wheng,
and I could tell it meant a lot to her
that I said her last name correctly.
Thank you, Nancy.
- I've heard my last name
butchered in so many different
ways that nothing really
phases me anymore.
We're all learning today.
Not really me, but definitely
a lot of other people are.
("Blue Danube")
- I'm really sorry, Nancy.
(laughing)
- It's okay, we're still good friends.
You want a hug?
- [friend] Yes.